the Joe Rogan experience the funniest
guys to me are guys that do characters
but themselves
yeah and they talk real like you know
that's why I mean you and burr you're
the same guys on an off stage you know
we're talking sometimes you get silly
sometimes you're serious right be just
be yourself yeah I know you're saying be
sincere but you can be just as [ __ ]
goofy as you want but don't stay in that
yeah it's so hacky to me it can be I'm
always waiting for someone to do it
right something I don't to pass judgment
like maybe one guy comes along and he's
in character all the time but it's
[ __ ] hilarious I just watched Jim
Carrey on the end when he did Andy
Kaufman yeah it was [ __ ] amazing oh
that was them the documentary that was
yeah that spring sprang from that but I
was watching the movie last night I
forget what it's called or something man
in the moon yeah man in the moon yeah
what Jim's good Oh brilliant you know
what's really interesting with him he's
taken like a severe psychological and I
guess philosophical turn where he's he's
just thought about life and things some
he must have had like some psychedelic
experiences too I think so it sounds
like it yeah because he's just talking
about like what matters and what doesn't
matter and you know and there's a bunch
of like interviews and clips of him
discussing things we like whoa like this
guy does not he's not talkin like Jim
Carrey the world-famous the a-list actor
who's had gigantic smash movies he's not
talking like that at all he's like
talking like some guy who's just trying
to sort of understand his place in the
universe yeah yeah it's really a really
profound way it's very well thought out
god you watch this thing about him
painting no it came out a couple months
we did we play this where some of those
paintings are really cool they're like
in neon and he talks about he says some
of the stuff that he's been thinking
about and dealing with so it's called I
need color and it's on Vimeo so folks
who go check that out yeah yeah I tell
you about the little part I have been
dying up here no okay so I play
Fitzie Anderson because they wouldn't
let me use fritzy Anderson remember 40
Anderson now
just to go on hello yeah and they
wouldn't let me it's parent I wouldn't
they said fritzy was a slur for two
Germans what yeah I sort of Jesus is
anyway I go into the Comedy Store in a
Thursday night why I was there just to
practice I know like real and trying a
couple lines and doing some [ __ ] and
Jim's in the audience
it comes out he hugs me anyway long
story short he he was with his boy his
ex-wife and they were their daughter was
ill and it's a great girl she's really
good singers too by the way but anyway
they start talking he said [ __ ] funny
Dom was she good he goes I want to put
him in this show and Melissa goes will
tell you one thing he's not gonna dance
free you want him yeah I asked him but
he ain't gonna audition because I'm not
gonna make my audition I'm known for
[ __ ] 30 years anyway that's how I got
the part and that funny
just randomly randomly he was he came in
to look for young comedian so I am NOT
one of them if you could tell boy I'm a
receding hairline but yeah I mean
amazing I mean just there that's
Thursday night randomly is that she'll
still going on
yeah we're shooting they're shooting ten
more I got a I know I'm doing an alcohol
an alcoholic the whole time which is I
never watched it I watched one episode
and I thought it was pretty good but I
heard that it was better yeah yeah I
heard that it was improving you know all
those things start yeah Seinfeld the
beginning I remember news radio the show
I didn't yeah it was clunky yeah it took
a while to really get rolling
yeah to get the rhythm what it is
sitcoms are very difficult you know I
mean one of the reasons why people like
oh boy they're any good sitcoms in the
air well goddamn it's hard to do well
this is a serious one
like I'm kind of the comic relief on
this because it's about like comedians
but not like you know when we goof
around Joe Rogan right not these it
won't see hardly any of that you see
them more like jealous of each other and
you know they're showing the dark side
of it the woman who plays the mitzi part
is Melissa Leo she's won the Academy
Award for some boxing movie I forget but
she she's playing Mitzi really serious
and I don't want to say anything you
know because she's a great actress but
if I were aghast to give one note I
would say they were MIT's he really had
a fun side to her mission by the way for
those EES don't know it was the owner
his own the owner of the Comedy Store
[Applause]